it's Lady Gaga's intimate backstage  moments with Beyonce taylor kinney then  while getting photographed Taylor  discreetly hangs in the background Gaga  had just sung her oscar-nominated song  till it happens to you then backstage we  see her with the songs co-writer Diane  Warren something else she didn't see out  front Leonardo DiCaprio rushing by  through the kitchen perhaps making his  getaway he was there to support his film  the revenue but it was the big short  that became the Oscar frontrunner with  its win is best motion picture for eight  straight years The Producers Guild Award  winner became the best picture oscar  winner this is so shocking I love your  reaction Viola Davis who presented boss  Shonda Rhimes with the Norman Lear  achievement award also got some love  herself from elle magazine your l cover  gave me goosebumps alright the old cover  cuz I felt like I looked like me you  know and I felt like me is enough